هذا المكب حيضل لمئه سنه قادمه لا يصلح
للاستخدام على الاطلاق هندسيا ممنوع
استخدامه
وممنوع البناء عليه واذا بدنا نرجع
نستخدمه ونعيد استصلاح هنحتاجه 100 سنه
لغايه ما الماده العضويه تتحلل ولا تاكد
انه ما في غازات بتطلع في المكان واللي هي
ممكن تحصى انفجار نتيجه انحباس الغازات
وتشكل الضغط والله احنا احنا قلقانين منها
لانه كل كل ماساه زي هذه في لها توابع
التوابع ممكن يعني بكره يبين مع الاولاد
مع النساء الحوامل ممكن يعني خايفين منها
كثير لانه يعني بدا الامور يعني مش طبيعيه
لانه هذه هذه ماساه موجوده تحت الارض
وبتصير علينا ميه وبطلع الغاز الميثان هذا
كل الليل بنزل علينا اشكاليتنا كبيره
واحنا خايفين على اولادنا في
المستقبلاتهم الامراض وفي ناس صابوا امراض
جلديه كمان من السالفه
[موسيقى]